faire les sucres c'est une tradition de
génération en génération chez la famille
thivierge
et à quelques exceptions près on a
conservé les méthodes de travail
d'autrefois un peu comme mon grand père
le faisait en fait ce sont des choses
qui on a amélioré on te promettons avec
un cheval maintenant quatre décennies on
simplifie la tâche un petit peu mais
disons que la goutte qui sort du
chalumeau et à sera la cabane est
presque la même manière
raquettes aux pieds ils vont d'arbre en
arbre pour recueillir l'eau d'érable
6700 chaudière est vide et ils se
portent ensuite le précieux liquide à la
cabane à sucre pour le transformer en
sirop pour nous c'est presque un peu des
vacances même son travail quand même dur
mais c'est le fait de décrocher un petit
peu mon garçon vient d'arriver dans le
fond est fini l'école y monte en moto
nice est une ville d'aramon s'est on
bosse paix à la cabane on va rester ici
en avoir ce soir martin thivierge fait
partie d'un groupe de séries cultes
heures qui souhaitent la création d'une
appellation traditionnels pour le sirop
fabriqués à l'ancien
avocat dans la vie de tous les jours
stéphane galibois plaide lui aussi en
faveur d'une certification
ça fait partie de notre histoire au
québec alors cette façon de faire de
récolter à la chaudière d'y aller
doucement et d'avoir un excellent
produit alors c'est un petit peu tout ce
qu'on veut à voir avec cette
reconnaissance lui sert au traditionnel
ça va être un bon signe vous
considérez comme une sommité du domaine
acéricole stéphane guillon fait partie
du comité derrière le projet
d'appellation on a besoin d'avoir un
témoin de ce que goûte un sirop fait de
façon traditionnelle parce qu'avec
toutes les nouveaux équipements on n
dérives de la saveur en fait on a une
perte de savoir graduelle dans
l'industrie pour qu'un sirop soit
considérée traditionnels il y aurait
essentiellement trois conditions
respecter l'eau d'érable devraient être
récoltées à la chaudière plutôt qu'avec
des tubes il faudrait utiliser un
évaporateur alimenté par un feu de bois
pour la cuisson
il serait interdit de recourir à un
système de filtration pour concentrer le
sucre dans l'eau d'érable ce qui permet
de la faire bouillir beaucoup moins
longtemps afin de la transformer en
sirop le temps de résidence dans
l'évaporateur des beaucoup plus court
puis ce temps de résidence le bain il
est important pour le développement des
savants c'est un peu comme n'importe
quelle recette si tu décides de faire
des feuilles volantes pts et cuit 20
minutes des feuilles volantes il ya bien
des chances qu'ils goûtent peau celle de
ta grand mère je compare souvent gain
rosbif confrères que dans une croix
neuve et l'autre ont fait cuire pendant
5 heures c'est sûr qu'ils étaient
persuadés convainquent personne que la
locution hollande va être meilleur il va
développer des goûts c'est une même même
chose le sirop martin thivierge pense
qu'une certification permettrait de
mettre en marche et le sirop d'érable
traditionnel plus facilement selon lui
il pourrait être vendu 50 % plus cher
que le sirop conventionnelle qu'on
retrouve dans les épiceries les géants
même portefeuille pour l'achat de leur
sirop mais s'ils comprennent que c'est
une qualité supérieure je pense puis
pour encourager aussi les plus petits
producteurs se sont en fait à plus
petite échelle karman fois que je
passais des bonnes raisons il pourrait
certainement valoir le double du sirop
qu'on retrouve un peu partout la kiffer
la tubulure savate un marché très
méchant qui vote destinés aux gens
curieux qui veulent goûter une fois dans
leur vie c'est quoi le travail fait de a
jusqu'à z stéphane galibois crois que
les consommateurs qui se laisseront
tenter par le sirop traditionnels ne
pourront pas revenir en arrière ce qui
est le sirop supérieur c'est lorsqu'il
goût d'érable très important et l'onl et
précise c'est particulier c'est l'europe
c'est notre produit le premier volet
c'est la saveur le deuxième volet c'est
protéger le patrimoine en fait d'un
savoir faire qu'on veut que les gens
gardent l'idée derrière sow c'est de
dire si un appellation le sirop bois se
vendent plus cher qui va avoir de plus
en plus de monde qui vont en faire à la
chaux diable
les producteurs déposeront leur demande
conseil des appellations réservées d'ici
le début de l'automne ils espèrent que
leur sirop d'érable pour arborer
fièrement la certification traditionnel
lors de la prochaine saison des sucres
et se lie vielles bachand réseau canada
à l'île d'orléans